Sebastian Lege zeigt, euch wie man
klassischen Hummus mithilfe von
Pflanzenfasern auf die doppelte Menge
strecken kann, wo die neue Lieblings-
zutat der Industrie überall drin
steckt und wie ihr sie auf der Verpackung
finden könnt.
Für den nächsten Trick brauchen wir richtig viel Bambus, aber nicht in dieser Form.
Und auch nicht in Form der beliebten Bambussprossen aus Asiagerichten.
Wertvoll für die Lebensmittelindustrie
ist vielmehr, was im harten Holz der
Pflanze steckt: Feine Bambusfasern. Denn
die lassen sich vielfältig nutzen.
Pflanzenfasern, der neue beliebte
Rohstoff der Lebensmittelindustrie, was
man da Verrücktes mit anstellen kann,
das sehen Sie jetzt. Pflanzenfasern sind
der neue Trend der Lebensmittelindustrie,
immer häufiger stecken sie in Produkten,
in denen wir sie eigentlich gar nicht
vermuten. Etwa in Frischkäse, Dips oder
Tortellini - aber warum?
Schließlich kommen die Original-
Rezepturen dieser Gerichte ganz ohne
Zusatz von Pflanzenfasern aus. Um den
Trick zu entlarven bereitet Sebastian
eine orientalische Leckerei zu, die auch
bei uns immer beliebter wird: Kichererbsen-Dip, sogenannter Hummus.
Traditionell mit sieben Zutaten. Die
Basis: Kichererbsen, gute anderthalb Kilo nimmt
Sebastian für seine Großportion.
Sesampaste. Sesam ist eine der
teuersten Zutaten im Hummus, aber
unentbehrlich für den Geschmack. Ebenso
wie Gewürze. Salz für den Geschmack, ein bisschen Knoblauch, Pfeffer,
gutes Olivenöl. Je mehr Olivenöl, desto
cremiger der Dip.
Einen Schluck Wasser
Deckel drauf.
Jetzt müssen die Kichererbsen püriert
und gründlich mit den anderen Zutaten
vermengt werden, dann ist der Hummus
fertig.
Und so schön cremig. Hmm, lecker. Nur gute Zutaten drin.
Die sieben Zutaten bilden die Basis jedes
Hummus und Bambusfasern, die kennt das
Originalrezept nicht. Doch für die
Industrie zählt nicht nur der Geschmack,
sondern auch die Menge. Aus 1,5 Kilo
Kichererbsen habe ich zwei Kilo
Kichererbsendip, sogenannten Hummus
gemacht. Der Produktentwickler weiß, mit
einem einfachen Trick geht da noch viel
mehr.
Jetzt kommen die Bambusfasern ins Spiel.
Anders als Sebastian, kaufen Lebensmittel-
hersteller die Bambusfasern als Fertigzutat - chemisch extrahiert, gereinigt und
getrocknet, ein feines, weißes Pulver.
Und jetzt demonstriert Sebastian das
Potential der Bambusfasern, dazu vermengt
er eine kleine Menge mit Wasser. In
Minutenschnelle entsteht eine breiige
Masse.
Das ist ja wie Tapetenkleister!
Wahnsinn, wie das bindet.
Die Bambusfasern sind aufgequollen, sie
binden die Flüssigkeit wie ein Schwamm,
so entsteht ein Füllstoff der vielfältig
einsetzbar ist.
Schmeckt total neutral, aber darum geht
es ja. Einen Füllstoff zu haben, der so neutral
ist wie es geht.
Ohne Geschmack, dafür mit extra Volumen.
Hmm, die leckere Bambusfaser.
Wie die Industrie auch, nutzt Sebastian diesmal
den Bambusfüllstoff.
Ansonsten nimmt er exakt die gleichen
Zutaten wie vorhin.
Die Sesampaste, Salz, eine Prise Pfeffer,
zumachen.
Sieben Zutaten insgesamt, plus Füllstoff.
Wahnsinn, sieht jetzt schon mehr aus wie
die Version, die vorher gemacht habe.
Der ganze Topf ist voll.
Zur Erinnerung: Die Originalrezeptur
ergab ein Glas Hummus. Und wie viel Zusatzmenge bringt nun der Bambus-Wasser-Füllstoff?
Das erste Glas ist schon mal voll. Jetzt
nehmen wir das Zweite. Jetzt zeigt sich der
Fasertrick. Sebastian hat jede Menge
Volumen dazu geschummelt, im Wesentlichen
Wasser, doch das fällt kaum auf. Wahnsinn!
Doppelt so viel Masse dank der
Bambusfaser.
Findige Fabrikanten können mit diesem
Trick also billig Volumen in ihre
Produkte pumpen und wir Kunden müssen
dann für Wasser teuer bezahlen.
Riecht wie Kichererbsendip, schmeckt genauso. Alles
da, so wie man es kennt, sind aber nicht
so viele Kichererbsen drin, wie man hofft.
Was bei Hummus funktioniert, gilt auch für
andere Produkte.
In Tortellinifüllung, Frischkäse,
Brotaufstrich und Saucen finden sich
ebenfalls oft Pflanzenfasern.
Auch aus Tomaten, Zitronen und Kartoffeln.
Pflanzenfasern in verschiedenen Produkten
klingen natürlich besonders natürlich
und der Hersteller suggeriert dem
Verbraucher, das ist jetzt ein besonders
natürliches Lebensmittel. Es ist aber
hier so, dass natürlich dieses nicht
dafür eingesetzt wurde, um den Nährwert
zu verbessern oder um unbedingt
Zusatzstoffe zu ersparen. Es ist hoch
verarbeitet und es sorgt auch dafür, dass wir mehr Volumen im Produkt
haben und da sollte sich der Verbraucher
immer bewusst sein. Bambusfasern
und Co, solche Pflanzenfasern dienen den
Herstellern also vor allem als Füllstoff
für volle Kassen.
Das nenne ich mal ein profitables
Geschäft, was so eine Faser alles drauf
hat.
In welchen Lebensmitteln sind euch schon
Pflanzenfasern aufgefallen? Sagt es uns
in den Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.